and i just rubbed this all over my face
that's the
that's the um suggestion
let's serve up some news sunny side up
insider reports that science says you
can
resist by using your old snifferoo
researchers at the university of florida
say that if you smell your favorite
snack for two minutes the craving can
disappear and you're basically tricking
your brain into thinking that you ate it
ross we're the guinea pigs today and
you've got a slice of za right in front
of you hello lover
right
all right let's give it a good whiff
okay
oh it does smell like pizza hi
i just want to motorboat it oh
gosh i don't know
okay well we're just going to keep on
sniffing until the end of the news and
then we'll really ask ourselves but does
anyone think this could work raise your
hands if you think it's like plausible
yeah
i'm finding hands i'm kind of with those
of you with your hands down now i want
pizza more than i have in months like
now i'm like
insider talked to amy and she said that
the first ideal meetup is the 30 minute
coffee she says this is a mini date it's
a perfect screener to let you know if
you want to do more sort of like a dip
and a toe in the pond instead of going
for a whole hog skinny dip taking a
nibble of that cheese before eating the
whole wheel rossi yeah in your single
days um did you have a perfect first
date formula
um
no
no
i you know didn't really date until i
was 28 i just was like i i didn't and
then i got in a 10-year relationship and
then i got out of that and then i
started dating and i you know it turns
out i was good at it i really was um and
i would have a lot of dates i wasn't
like you know i wasn't hooking up right
but i was saying but i'll tell you i
don't think the coffee date is a great
idea really why uh well a couple reasons
one if you meet up and it's great like i
suggest going to a happy hour because if
it's great you could slide that day into
a dinner right and if it's horrible
you're drunk all right
[Applause]
we just learned about a real quirky way
jessica simpson she likes to eat
breakfast we have to talk about this
people report she posted a pic of her
and her daughter maxwell sharing some
bacon which i love bacon and she
admitted that when she eats bacon she
only eats
the tips
that's the tip
what just the tip yeah
no no
okay
and herky
okay
don't do this to me
i do have to say the tip is always the
crispiest part right of the bacon
[Applause]
you know
i have a highly addictive personality
and i don't think i can do it i gotta go
whole hog here okay
[Applause]
today we're trying the latest skin care
trend
glamour reports that the frozen cucumber
trick is going viral and dermatologists
say
they might have something to this cute
are loaded with vitamin k can reduce
puffiness and help with acne and dark
circles so we have frozen cucumbers here
these are legit so cold that we wrapped
a towel around them and i just rub this
all over my face
that's the
that's the um suggestion
okay but guess what
what we have someone in our audience
who's gonna do this with us hi who's
this hi oh it's kat ladies and gentlemen
hi camera warm welcome
are we going to really do this on
television i'm ready kat i would like
you to lead this beauty session
i'm going to start at the eye area
because that feels
more appropriate okay
oh my god that's so cold whoa smells
nice
it does feel like like a like a real
product that you'd buy at a store though
you know a grocery store
the new york post reports that a british
man named darren dowling recently shared
a pic of what his hotel room looks like
when he's finished with it you seeing
that little camping trip he set up there
all right well before he checks out he
strips the bed and leaves everything in
little piles
this blew me away i i i feel like i'm a
pretty good human being right you are
thank you i know you you are but i've
never done that
when you leave that's the nicest thing
should we all be doing this drew do you
do this i've never stripped the bed but
i have an obsession
and it is cleaning hotel rooms before i
check out
um i will not leave them dirty if i if
there are towels i can pile them um i
make the bed even if it's just sort of
like you know it doesn't have to be
hospital corners levels because i know
it's going to get undone again you know
i'm not really surprised by this at all
drew
[Music]
does anyone else do this
i mean i i feel like i do it like this
and it just falls off well that's why
because you gotta wrap it here and then
you fold it over once and sometimes i'll
even fold it over twice because then
you're just like i don't know i i feel
like i'm in the blue lagoon i've got my
loin cloth but why is mine's so short
though drew what this is not look at liv
that's not a cute look someone whistled
do not
pity me
[Music]
you